la publication des caricatures de
mahomet dans france-soir et charlie
hebdo suscite de nouvelles
manifestations
cet après midi 2000 personnes à
strasbourg et cette nuit là parmi les ou
de religion hier le conseil du culte
board et d'engagement citoyen fabious
dès le départ le ton est donné entre
ambiance bonne enfant soucis
d'organisation et fébrilité car c'est
bien la colère aiguë s'est nullement
qu'il essaie de sortir dans la rue pour
dénoncer public les caricatures de
mahomet dans des jo français et le
prophète si les messages et des dieux ne
font pas long feu a touché c'est pas
quelqu'un comme moi un gros con qui est
à bloc et à la liberté d'expression et y
à résoudre est en fait en tant que
démocrate dit écoeuré public
tout le monde se doit de respecter
l'islam comme ça me l'a dit les slogans
se veulent pas l'apaisement et au refus
de la provocation nous à l'heure de
prière le choix des lieux ou pas anodin
et hors microcar bricoler c'est d'abord
du mal vivre des musulmans en france
dont chacun veut parler y aura presque
une partie de ce collectif
oui à la barre chromée n'ont alors
d'autre diffamation sous le regard de
nombreuses télévisions rangèrent il
était ainsi ce défilé remis à drop
entend officiel culte musulman les
masses temps répondaient à l'appel d'un
collectif d'associations de saint denis
qui exige une révision de la loose
avions émis l'idée de voir interdire par
aboient je nous sens dans un pays de
droit
toute dérive
deux des médias donc concernant quelques
croyances que ce soit un mouvement suivi
également à strasbourg où ils étaient
2000 musulmans à manifester